Over in the horse race,
it's, uh, not looking too good
for President Biden.
He's now losing to all three
of the top Republican contenders
-and there is some--
-(AUDIENCE MEMBER APPLAUDS)
-Okay.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
We want all opinions here,
that's fine. But-- (LAUGHS)
But, uh, yeah,
and there's something very bad
politically looming for him
next week, his birthday.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Uh...
He would like to avoid this.
He's, uh, gonna be 81.
We've never had a president
who's 81.
Doesn't mean he can't do it,
I'm just saying. I like the guy,
but I'm just saying
if Joe Biden was a balcony,
uh, I wouldn't step out on him
for a smoke.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-The way I put it, but...
So-- (LAUGHS)
And, uh, oh, the Republicans,
they spent the week threatening
to beat each other up.
(SMACKS LIPS)
I'm... I'm not making this up.
Here's a new--
Now, I didn't know this,
I had never heard this name
before this week.
Apparently,
he's a senator from Oklahoma,
Markwayne Mullin. Mark...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Sounds like a serial killer,
actually a senator.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Senator Markwayne Mullin
was hearing te... (CHUCKLES)
...testimony from the head
of the Teamsters Union.
And at one point, he stands up,
takes off his ring.
-Like, "Let's go, bro."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
This is the Senate!
Mitch McConnell
completely froze.
-Then he heard about the...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
All right.
You're way ahead of me.
(LAUGHS) But they-- Can I--
Can I recreate for you
a little bit the actual dialogue
that went on
in the United States Senate
between this man and a senator.
First guy says,
"You wanna do it now?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
"I'd love to do it now."
"Then stand your butt up."
"You stand your butt up!"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Again, this is a senator,
Mark-- That's his--
Markwayne Mullin,
his campaign slogan,
"Markwayne Mullin,
what the fuck
are you looking at?"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
And then--
And then... (SCOFFS)
...another congressman
claimed former, recently former,
uh, House Speaker, head dude,
Kevin McCarthy, sucker punched
him in the kidney.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And Kevin McCarthy said,
"Hey, if I did that,
he'd be on the ground."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
It's so fucking embarrassing
watching these pencil necks
trying to act all hard.
Yeah, Kevin McCarthy, hard.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He's got a tear tattoo.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
For the time he killed Medicare.
Anyway.